london's police chief says this morning
the death toll will rise in the
devastating London apartment fire
firefighters put out the last of the
flames this morning more than a day
after the massive fire broke out 17
people are confirmed dead at this time
dozens of others are believed to be
missing 74 people are hurt
Prime Minister Theresa May went to the
building this morning and promised an
investigation during an emotional visit
overnight singer Adele hugged and
comforted people their memorial to those
who died is growing nearby and Jonathan
Vigliotti is close to the scene in
London with new details on the
investigation Jonathan good morning Jeff
the building behind me looks like a
skeleton many of these floors completely
gutted by these flames firefighters are
actually back here on the scene battling
hotspots these small pockets of flames
fire officials say at this hour this
building is still too dangerous to gain
total access inside the morning after
reveals what a day of raging flames did
to this 24 story apartment the damage so
severe fire officials say it will take
weeks to inspect each and every floor
for now drones are the safest tool for
investigators the cause of the fire is
still unclear as is how it spreads so
quickly fire experts believe the
cosmetic cladding or siding recently
added to the building's exterior may be
to blame the cladding sets just outside
the wall yeah and then there is this
space between it and you're saying
because it was installed incorrectly
oxygen was able to get through which a
chimney effect brought that fire up
sometime during that fire the cladding
has become involved and then it spread
vertically at the facade of the building
Joe ray Wayne conducts fire tests on
buildings
if you imagine a fire on the ground
floor and the chimney effect acting like
a flue it's carrying the fire through
the wind as well up the facade of the
building the fire struck in the middle
of the night
trapping many some seen desperately
screaming for help
we warn you that the video from inside
the building is disturbing it was shot
on the 23rd floor we have no information
of the person who took the video
survived survivors say they spent years
complaining about fire hazards including
blocked exits but say the management
company wasn't responsive more than a
dozen are still missing their faces
posted around a growing donation center
for the hundreds now left homeless and
the construction company that put in
that cladding said in a statement that
they met all fire regulations cadaver
dogs are now being brought into this
building to search for bodies of the
missing charlie the BBC spoke with a
firefighter who fears as many as 100
people may have been killed Jonathan
Vigliotti in London thank you so much